Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen Tim.
So ein Podcast nicht toll. Hier kannst du doch machen, was du schon immer machen wolltest.
Und das straflos.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die einhundertvierundsechzigste Ausgabe und die letzte aus der Meta-Ebene in diesem Jahr.
Was jetzt für euch eigentlich auch komplett irrelevant ist. Für uns nicht ganz so irrelevant, weil demnächst brechen wir dann zum Kongress auf,
dann am Ende der Sendung auch nochmal ein bisschen was dazu. Ansonsten war irgendwas? Also Herr Maaßen, ähm.
Ist ein attraktiver Arbeitgeber.
Ja. Ist erstaunlich, oder?
Also ob der.
Man fragt sich schon wirklich, ist das mal einspielen?
Ja, ja.
Spiel das mal ein, das ist einfach so hanebüchen.
Das ist.
Was den so reitet? Großartig.
Metronaut hat ja dann auch direkt die neue Werbekampagne des äh Verfassungsschutz äh geliebt.
Äh na ja so,
Bei uns können sie all das machen, was sie schon immer mal machen wollten unter Straflos und dann halt so, ja, so Thüringer Heimatschutz, äh Nazischmierereien, Aktenschreddern, Leute abhören,
Ja ich äh ja was willst du denn dazu sagen?
Sie zu sagen, das lassen wir jetzt einfach mal so im Raum.
Das lassen wir so sacken und ich denke, das spricht für sich und wer da Interesse hat, äh kann dann da.
Genau. Und weißt du noch in der letzten Sendung haben wir das doch so ausführlich über den den äh Grundrechtekatalog von Herrn Maaß, also von Maaßen zu Maß. Ähm unterhalten? Oder meintest du ja noch,
Ja, das ist ja so allgemein gehalten. Da kann ja jetzt da kannst du ja irgendeinen beliebigen CSU-Politiker rauspicken und der würde das genauso unterschreiben.
Ja, habe ich die Rechnung ohne Öttinger gemacht.
Ja
Weil, ja, ist da auf jeden Fall äh kommt da sozusagen nochmal die Expects, das kommt der so aus dem Wald gesprungen und meint so, nein, kein Bedarf
Für eine digitale Grundrechte Charta, weil nicht? Wir haben ja jetzt alles im Prinzip schon und jetzt also weitere Grundrechte, wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Dass das äh da dieses Interview ist eh ganz schön, weil es äh mit einer das ein Zeitinterview äh und da geht, das geht los mit der Frage, Herr Öttinger, Sie haben gerade die Chance, die Welt zu verändern. Werden Sie es tun?
Ja, sagt nicht wirklich ja.
Nee, er sagt einfach nur, in welcher Form. Ähm na ja. Genau, also wir haben jemanden gefunden,
das passiert mir nicht nochmal, dass ich die Rennung ohne den Oettinger mache. Ja.
Dann haben wir äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die Vorrat, die Tinte unter der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja immer noch nicht ganz trocken,
Da äh kommen sie ja alle aus ihren Löchern.
Genau, weil wenn das ja erstmal wieder beschlossen ist, dann kommen wir wie beim letzten Mal auch schon, also die tollen Ideen, ah echt super, jetzt haben wir da könnte man ja noch das und das machen.
Klassiker sind ja eigentlich immer so die Aufweichung, ne? So erst heißt es ja immer so, ja, das darf ja nur bei besonders begründeten und fällen und Terrorismus und schwerer Sachen und dann kommen sie alle an, na ja aber kiffen wir ja auch eigentlich auch ganz schön, wenn man das damit eingesammelt bekommen und Hütchenspieler und so,
Aber äh ja, unsere Freunde aus Bayern haben da mal so eine ganz geile Idee ausgegraben,
der Meinung, man könnte doch mal den bayrischen Verfassungsschutz äh mit diesen Telekommunikationsdaten, die da so schön abgegriffen werden, ausstatten, weil,
nicht sein.
Es kann ja nicht sein. Es kann ja nicht sein, äh dass unsere Nachrichtendienste weniger wissen als Polizei und Strafverfolgungsbehörden. Das kann ja nun wirklich nicht sein,
denkt sich der, der gute Innenminister Joachim Herrmann, natürlich von der von einer der C-Parteien gestellt, in diesem Fall der CSU,
Weil es Bayern ist,
und sagt dann, die verheerende Anschläge in Paris, da da da, da haben wir dann schön Paris dabei und ähm
dieser Gesetzesentwurf, den die bayrische Regierung da jetzt beschlossen hat, der muss dann noch durch den,
durch den Landtag und ja, effektiv würde das bedeuten, in dem Moment, wo dann der Verfassungsschutz,
Beschließt jetzt mal jemanden Telekommunikations zu überwachen, äh soll er denn eben auch gleichzeitig direkt diesen zehn,
äh den zehn Wochen Backlock bekommen, der in den äh Vorratsdatenspeicherungen drin hängt. Es ist so interessant, dass man.
Das haben wir ja alles schon gesagt, ne. Das ist jetzt auch immer so schwierig, da nochmal die ähm also es ist einerseits schwierig, da jetzt Empörung zu heucheln. Es ist andererseits auch irgendwie überhaupt nicht,
Ziel führt, dazu sagen, haben wir doch gesagt, also was soll man da sagen so?
Kann man nicht sagen,
Einfach nur zur Kenntnis nehmen und vielleicht auch nochmal für die Leute, für die das nicht ganz so selbstverständlich ist, warum wir äh uns über solche Vorschläge so aufregen. Einfach nochmal sagen, diese ganze Trennung von Polizei und Geheimdiensten,
Das ist halt einfach mal so eine eine der Kern lehren aus der Nazizeit,
und äh einfach um nicht wieder in so
äh Situationen zu geraten, wo man einfach eine geheimarbeitende Polizei hat, ja, also geheime Staatspolizei, die sozusagen ohne rechtliche äh,
rechtlich abgesegnete äh Mittel der der Bevölkerung nachgeht.
Deswegen ist diese diese Trennung einfach auch so stark. Und ich denke, das ist auch,
Einer der Kerngründe, warum in unserem Umfeld das auch so genau genommen wird.
Also er hat natürlich einen, also wir haben einmal diese ähm die Trennung. Äh wir haben natürlich noch diesen, diesen anderen Aspekt, der,
Im Prinzip,
im Prinzip hat er ja Recht, diese Trennung soll ja eigentlich immer sein, so verfassungs äh äh also der der Verfassungsschutz als Inlandsgeheimdienst darf dich,
Überwachen ohne dir nachher Bescheid zu sagen,
Der darf dich aber nicht in Knast bringen. Die Polizei darf dich in den Knast bringen, aber die muss auch über alle ihre Ermittlungs Methoden Rechenschaft ablegen,
Äh insofern ist das natürlich schon ganz kannte ich verstehen, dass der sagt, naja Moment mal, der Verfassungsschutz ist doch der, der alles
können darf, dann kann es doch nicht sein, dass er keinen Zugriff auf die Vorratsdaten bekommt, ja? Also.
Das ist schon diese Argumentation kann ich erstmal,
nachvollziehen. Der Fehler ist natürlich sowieso, dass wir diese Daten überhaupt sammeln, ja? Also da das ist ja der, der, der eigentliche Kritikpunkt, den wir hier halt auch nicht vergessen dürfen.
Und das jetzt ein äh Verfassungsschutz darauf zugreift, dass auf Daten, die da sind, äh Geheimdienste zugreifen wollen,
Ist ja jetzt auch nix Neues. Insofern ähm war davon war abzusehen, dass eine solche Forderung kommen würde und die wird auch, Bayern sieht sich da ja als,
in der Vorreiterrolle. Freistaat, ja, ähm.
Da wird er auch darauf hoffen können, dass dann andere dieser Idee folgen werden.
Ciao. Aber die äh CSU macht sich so mit ihrem Auftreten nicht unbedingt jetzt so äh immer Freude, ja.
Also man hat ja schon hier krasse Reaktionen gesehen, ne. Also unter anderem hat Jesus angekündigt, seinen Nachnamen äh zu ändern, um sich.
Von der CSU zu distanzieren.
Von der CSU zu distanzieren. Das sind dann einfach so Konsequenzen, mit denen man nicht äh so ohne Weiteres gerechnet hat und wo dann vielleicht die CSU nochmal ein bisschen drüber nachdenken muss, ne.
Genau.
Ach ja.
Okay.
Wird. Auf dem Weg wirklich mal eine kurze Sendung zu machen. Auch schon beim zweiten Thema.
Ah ja.
Geht mit dem flammen Schwert voran und befreit das Internet von Hate Speech. Das war, glaube ich, der Plan.
Der hatte ja vor einiger Zeit dann eben da sein Einschreiten ähm angekündigt und ist dann ja in irgendwelche bilateralen Verhandlungen mit,
Mit den Social Networks gegangen, mit,
Facebook und Twitter hat ja da glaube ich gesprochen und präsentiert jetzt äh stolz, dass die Unternehmen sich verpflichten, Beschwerden künftig umgehend durch spezialisierte Teams prüfen zu lassen.
Da fällt mir direkt ein, dass ich ja die Leute, die in diesem Tee, in diesen Teams arbeiten, die kenne ich ja sogar persönlich. Also es gibt,
diese Teams und es gibt diese Leute, die die Beschwerden prüfen, ja? Das war ja.
Wie du kennst sie persönlich.
Ich habe auch schon Leute kennengelernt, die bei Facebook in der äh Treuebändigungszensurbehörde arbeiten. Natürlich, klar, gibt's,
Wenn du da irgendwie dich über einen äh Beitrag beschwerst, dann geht das ja an jemanden, also dieses dieser Meldeknopf hat eine Konsequenz.
Irgendwann,
in grauer Zukunft. Also es gibt da Menschen. Also es wird jetzt halt als Erfolg dargestellt, dass der Mars jetzt irgendwie denen das eingeredet hätte, aber die das haben sie ja schon immer. Das die Schwierigkeit war, dass sie der Menge nicht wirklich Herr geworden sind.
Beziehungsweise, dass ihre Kriterien äh auch fragwürdig sind.
Genau und deswegen wird jetzt als Erfolg gefeiert. Das wäre also bislang nicht immer der Fall gewesen, dass so eine Meldung bei einem spezialisierten Team ähm landet. Und
der Maßstab für die Prüfung wird nun das deutsche Recht sein und nicht mehr lediglich die eigenen Standards des jeweiligen Netzwerks, ähm die ja bei Facebook sehr ähm,
in der amerikanischen Tradition der Meinungsfreiheit stehen,
Und äh als Konsequenz sollen rechtswidrige Inhalte, wie beispielsweise Volksverhetzung oder Aufrufe zu Gewalt, ähm unverzüglich entfernt werden, spätestens innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden.
Tja, ähm.
Ich also für mich klingt das so ein bisschen nach,
Also, er mal vorweg, ich habe ja schon mehrmals ausgeführt, dass ich das nicht, dass ich diese Löscherei eher nicht für ähm,
für die Methode der Wahl halte. Ähm rechtswidrig ist ohnehin ein sehr strenges Kriterium,
aber wahrscheinlich auch das das Richtige und Notwendige. Interessanterweise ist es aber so, dass ja schon die heutige Rechtsprechung genau das hergibt, ja, dass Facebook für die Inhalte der Nutzer nicht,
Ähm,
haftet, nicht verantwortlich ist, es sei denn, die sind rechtswidrig und Facebook hat Kenntnis dadurch. Das heißt, genau das, was da jetzt getan wird, rechtswidrige Inhalte werden gemeldet und,
dann werden sie in letzter Konsequenz eben auch gelöscht.
Oder müssen gelöscht werden.
Müssen gelöscht werden, ist äh letztendlich das, was was ohnehin der Rechtsrahmen heute sowieso schon hergibt. Also da ist da ist rechtlich jetzt nix geschehen, ja. Ich habe so ein bisschen eher den Eindruck, dass die sich da ähm,
Zusammengesetzt haben und gesagt haben, na ja okay, äh Facebook ist irgendwie ein bisschen blöd in äh in den Medien gewesen wegen Hate Speech äh Justizminister hat gesagt
äh wir machen da jetzt was, wie ist unsere gemeinsame Pressemitteilung, dass am Ende keiner sein Gesicht oder sein äh sein äh Einkommen, sein Gewinn verliert
und wir irgendwie aus der Nummer äh rauskommen und sagen, schön haben wir alle was gemacht, ja. Mehr ist da ja nicht passiert. Ähm.
Genau. Insgesamt ich, also ich, wie gesagt, ich glaube, da ist nix geschehen. Da wird sich jetzt nix ändern.
Und ich glaube, dass eben andere Methoden des Umgangs mit äh solchen Leuten die besseren sind, diese Löscherei halte ich, wie gesagt, für ähm,
Ja, etwas, was diesen Menschen auch vielleicht die Möglichkeit nimmt, Feedback zu bekommen zu ihren Gedanken und das Feedback natürlich, wie ich das gerne habe, in Form von Spott.
Ja gut, aber du weißt auch, dass es nicht immer zu machen ist.
Genau, bei der, bei der Grenze rechtswidrig oder bei der, bei der Schwelle rechtswidrig und so sieht das eben.
Ja, vor allem mal sowas, was da auch teilweise äh nicht nur teilweise, also was da sozusagen auch massenhaft
an ähm Gewaltandrohung und Verhetzung stattfindet. Ich meine dasselbe auf der Straße, man müsste halt auch sofort die Polizei rufen.
Und das das ist halt so das Problem. Und wisst ihr jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so recht,
wie man da jetzt Facebook sonst entgegentreten sollte.
Also ich meine, was, was, was, was könnte deiner Meinung nach eine Alternative zum, ich lösche das sein?
Bei bei rechtswidrigen Inhalten irgendwie Gewaltaufruf oder sowas. Meinst du jetzt?
Ja, also ich meine, was auch immer jetzt hier unter Hate Speech konkret in diesen Diskussionen diskutiert wurde, weiß ich nicht, aber es gibt halt die offensichtlichen äh Sachen, also wenn da jetzt irgendwie zum wir fackeln mal ein Flüchtlingsheim ab, dann ist das halt einfach mal.
Das ist klar. Ähm.
Das ist aber auch nicht das Hauptproblem, was also ich hatte,
Ich hatte ja vor einiger Zeit mal diesen Vortrag, wo ich meine Sicht der dazu geschildert habe und im Anschluss gab's eine ähm,
eine Podiumsdiskussion, wir verlinken das nochmal in den und da war ein äh ich habe mich ja mit mehreren social Media Redakteuren unterhalten,
und das, was sie schildern, ist eben weniger, dass es dass das Problem in diesen sozialen Netzwerken wäre, dass offenkundig rechtswidrige Inhalte sind,
rechtswidrige Kommentare da sind, wo konkret zu einer Straftat aufgerufen wird, das ist eher,
Die Seltenheit, sondern ähm dieses unterschwellige, weißt du, dieses,
wo du genau weißt, wie die Leute denken, aber die jetzt nicht über irgendeine Grenze gehen, das ist das, worunter die ganzen Social Media Leute äh eigentlich so zu leiden haben, dass sie nämlich genau unter der Schwelle sind,
die meisten ähm hasserfüllten Kommentare, wo man sie irgendwie,
Wo man sie einer, eines konkreten Verstoßes ähm bezichtigen könnte.
Das ist das, was wir von mehreren Leuten so geschildert wird. Und für die muss man eben auch einen anderen Umgang finden und das wird sich dadurch eben auch nicht klären.
Diese Einigung. Diese Einigung ist und das ist eigentlich das, also wir reden aber schon wieder viel zu lange drüber, das ist halt irgendwie eine Pressemitteilung, die jetzt irgendwie her musste, weil man da was losgetreten hat und wahrscheinlich vor irgendeinem vor irgendeiner ähm vor irgendeiner Kamera ein bisschen zu großspurig aufgetreten ist, insbesondere eben unser lieber Freund
Heiko Maas hier. Also da wird sich jetzt nichts da passiert jetzt nichts. Das ist jetzt eine PM,
Noch dazu kommt natürlich mein vierundzwanzig Stunden ist in so einer Social Media World, wo äh in so einer Timeline äh fünf Beiträge pro Minute einprasseln, ist halt vierundzwanzig Stunden irgendwie sowas wie
wir verbrennen die Zeitung von vorgestern, ja? Also das ist na ja.
Ich freue mich ja, mit was für einem Newsflow diese Leute dort zu kämpfen haben, die,
also wie viele Nachrichten kriegen die wirklich so pro Sekunde vor die Nase gesetzt und haben die überhaupt genug Personal? Äh um das abzufackeln. Also das kann auch sehr gut sein, dass,
sie einfach total überfordert sind.
Das Problem ist dieses oder der der Witz ist dieses Personal,
Das Problem ist eigentlich nicht dieses Personal zu bezahlen, weil das ist ja jetzt auch keiner, der der äh hochbezahlten Jobs da, Kommentardompteur zu sein,
So, dass jetzt nicht irgendjemand, der da musste jetzt keine besonders besonderen Leute verhaben,
bei Facebook jetzt, ne, bei den, bei den äh Redaktionen, die das selber machen, die jetzt so süddeutsch oder so, ist das natürlich was anderes, da musst du Leute haben, die in der Lage sind, an diesen Diskursen äh sich zu beteiligen, ne? Aber jetzt irgendwie bei Facebook äh Lösch äh,
Löschkollege zu sein, da das da in den Job kommst du ganz gut. Das Problem ist eher, dass den keiner machen will. Ja, weil der dir auf die Laune schlägt.
Ja, eben. Also ich denke mal, dass sie eine relativ hohe Fluktuation da haben durften in diesen Abteilungen. Also ob das wirklich mal so einfach ist, da Leute äh zu bekommen, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber was natürlich auch und das ist auch ein mahnender Hinweis, ist natürlich so, offenbar wird dann da jetzt die Lösch.
Die Löschkapazität ausgebaut werden, die Zensurkapazität, ne? Und wir wissen, was dann passiert. Deswegen, wie gesagt, wer's mir persönlich lieber gewesen, wenn man für diese ganzen Idioten eine Lösung findet, die,
nicht unbedingt mit löschen einhergeht.
Auch wenn ich weiß, dass das eine äh Position ist, die nicht viele teilen. Aber das habe ich, wie gesagt, in meinem Vortrag ausgeführt und habe jetzt auch keine Lust mehr übers Thema zu sprechen.
Okay. Dann blicken wir nach Europa. Ähm werden ja hier auch gerade in den letzten Sendungen nochmal,
auf das ganze Geschehen rund um die neue EU-Datenschutzverordnung äh gesprochen, auf den Film hingewiesen,
der ist ja mittlerweile jetzt auch in die Kinos geschafft haben dürfte, ich hab's nicht verfolgt, aber.
Ja doch, der hatte sein Kin.
Der läuft noch, ne?
In der zweiten äh zweiten Dezemberwo.
Also wer den noch nicht gesehen hat, könnte auch noch äh Glück haben in den Kinos. Ich weiß nicht, keine, keine Ahnung, wie wie viel Theatern der jetzt irgendwie läuft und wie gut der insgesamt angenommen wurde.
Ähm der wird der wird, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, in Hamburg in einem Kino gezeigt, in der Zeit, wo auch der Kongress ist,
Also es gibt irgendwie so eine äh
Kongress in der Nähe des Kongress ein Kino, wo das dann, wo der Film dann gezeigt wird und irgendwie Kongressbesucher können rüber gehen oder sowas.
Habe das nicht mehr, habe das nicht genau verfolgt, aber das flog an mir vorbei und wer beim Kongress ist, wird da die Gelegenheit haben, sich dann abends nochmal irgendwie ein Kino rüberzusetzen.
Okay, schaut bei mir schon aus, falls wir das noch äh finden, dann setzen wir das noch mit rein. Aber es geht ja jetzt gar nicht um den Film, sondern es geht
darum, dass wir noch ausstehenden, abschließenden Verhandlungen zwischen dem äh Europäischen Rat
und dem ähm der Kommission und dem Parlament
anstand, also der Trilog. Ja, man erinnert sich, der vor kurzem ja auch für Netzneutralität, nicht ganz so brillanten Ergebnissen äh durchgeführt worden ist und jetzt eben auch für die EU-Datenschutz äh Reform und der ist jetzt,
abgeschlossen worden. Es gibt ein finales äh einen finalen Vorschlag und ja. Man ist sich wohl einig. Ähm,
Bisher hat jetzt noch niemand aus unserem Umfeld geschweige denn uns äh das Ergebnis, glaube ich, schon vollständig durchgelesen, aber so wenn man jetzt mal den ersten Reaktionen äh glauben darf, bei den üblichen Verdächtigen sind jetzt die,
Leute, die das vor allem in der Form durchgezogen haben, nicht unglücklich. Sie haben Kompromisse gemacht,
Aber meinen, das wäre im Wesentlichen schon das Paket, was man beschlossen habe.
Wir reden um das kurz zu wir reden hier von etwas über zweihundert Seiten, ja? Die zu beurteilen ähm dauert ein bisschen.
Sogar Oettinger findet das ist äh toll ist.
Das macht mich das macht mich ein bisschen nervös, weil Oettinger wieder sagt, ah, die Konsumenten werden profitieren.
Und die unteren Unternehmen auch.
Nehmen. Das ist wieder so eine äh.
Ja, aber Axel Voss von der CDU sieht ja noch verbesserungsbedarf, von daher kann's jetzt so äh schlimm auch nicht sein.
Nee, das ist, also ich fand, genau, das ist das ist eigentlich da, wo ich dachte, ah okay, dann äh.
Ja, also Bitcom und so, meint so, ja, na ja, das wäre alles nicht praktisch umsetzbar, aber äh schön, dass wir jetzt zumindest eine einheitliche Regelung haben, weil das ist jetzt sozusagen das Ergebnis, es wird dann eine einheitliche Richtlinie bezüglich Datenschutzstandards geben
und was man sich ja davon erhofft, unter anderem ist eben, dass dieses ganze äh Unternehmen wie Facebook, Apple, et cetera, weichen aus nach Irland, weil sie da einfach äh bessere Bedingungen in dieser Hinsicht vorfinden, dass es dann,
Ich weiß nicht, ob's gleich Geschichte ist, aber das ändert zumindest erstmal die Vorzeichen in diesem Spiel, doch erheblich und dann muss man natürlich bewerten, nach einiger Zeit, was es am Ende alles,
gebracht haben wird.
Genau, diesen Kompromiss, der da jetzt ausgehandelt wurde, den müssen die Mitgliedsstaaten und das EU Parlament noch absägen, segnen, absegen.
Herr Voss, will den noch absägen und die anderen segnen.
Oh Mann, ey, das die müssen den noch absägen,
Oh Mann, ey, mein Gott. Das war ein äh das ich hoffe, dass dass ähm,
Das ist nicht der Fall sein wird, aber das könnte ein visionärer, freundlicher Versprecher werden.
Absegnen,
und dann äh dann haben wir da würde sie zwanzig achtzehn in Kraft treten ungefähr, ja.
Erst. Oh, na ja gut. Dann wird doch noch nicht gleich alles gut.
Ne. Ja. So ist es. So. Ja.
Ja, insofern mal eigentlich ganz gute äh Nachrichten soweit. Eine kleine haben wir noch,
Und zwar hatten wir ja schon äh öfter hier auch über das sogenannte Redube ähm Verfahren gesprochen. Das ist diese Abmahn ähm Saga, wo,
die äh das Anwaltsbüro Urman gegen.
Ich glaube, das war Urmann und Kollegen.
Und Kollegen noch.
Kollegen mit C geschrieben. Ja, daran erinnere ich mich dann noch.
Ja, so was. Gibt's wohl jetzt nicht mehr.
Diese gibt's schon länger nicht mehr. Die sind Ende zwanzig vierzehn platt gegangen.
Aber du weißt ja auch nicht, warum jetzt.
Ich denke mal, weil ihr scheiß Name verbrannt war und sie jetzt unterirgend.
Ja, also es kann gut sein, dass dass diese Rettube nun mal, das war dann einfach mal zu viel, ne? Kriegen wir's technisch noch zusammen? Also, das hatte ja was mit diesem Streaming äh zu tun.
Die haben Leute abgemahnt für das Betrachten von Streams. Und das ist,
Äh haben dafür ein technisches Verfahren genutzt, dass sie nicht in keiner Form irgendwie technisch transparent erklärt haben. Wir haben ein ein Sachverständigengutachten vorgelegt ähm,
dass die dass die Funktion dieses technischen Verfahrens bestätigen sollte. Und ähm.
Dieses dieses Sachverständig-Gutachten war im Prinzip ja, wir haben den Stream geguckt und nachher war unsere IP in der Liste,
So und äh mehr nicht, also haben über
in keiner Form erklärt, was jetzt, sage ich mal, die die juristische Bewandtnis und der die Legitimation dieses Verfahrens als Beweismittel in einem juristischen Vorgang ähm
anginge oder so und haben sich dann ähm,
mit damit vom Gericht oder mit Hilfe dieses Gutachtens vor Gericht äh die ähm die IP-Adresse von Nutzern geben lassen und haben dann da den großen äh Abmahnsampano gemacht. Und dann haben sich einige Nutzer gewehrt,
und das Ganze hatte ja ein ein längeres Nachspiel und jetzt gibt es ein äh Urteil aus Regensburg vom Amtsgericht äh vom achten zwölften.
Mit dem sowohl dieser äh Thomas Uhrmann von Uhrmann und Kollegen, als auch die Z9 äh Verwaltungs GmbH,
ähm gesamtschuldnerisch zum Schadensersatz verurteilt wurden.
Und gegenüber dem Herrn Thomas Urmann wurde festgestellt, dass mit dem, was er dort getan hat, mit dieser Abmahnkampagne eine vorsätzlich begangene, unerlaubte Handlung vorliegt.
Und es liegen ausreichende Anhaltspunkte für ein arg listiges Verhalten des Beklagten vor,
ja? Das ist äh das ist schon hart, äh wenn du als Anwalt ähm,
dich Sofa verballerst, dass du,
Ich meine, eigentlich bist du ja ganz gut darin geschult worden, ähm das Recht ähm auszulegen.
Und wenn dir dann so was geschieht, dann äh hast du hast du schön einen offenen Sack bekommen.
Ja, das kostet dann irgendwie zweihundertein Euro einundsiebzig plus Zinsen.
Was nenne ich.
Pro Tag, wenn ich das richtig sehe seit dem siebten dritten, zwanzig vierzehn, ich weiß nicht, bis wann das zählt. Diese Gerichte sind immer so ein bisschen,
In ihren Formulierungen oder.
Na ja, wir sind, wir müssen da jetzt keine Urteile lesen, ich glaube.
Es war auf jeden Fall teuer.
Das wird teuer und irgendwie als Anwalt äh für arglistiges Verhalten verurteilt zu sein und für
auf Schadensersatz sowie vorsätzlich begangene unerlaubte Handlungen das ist doch schön.
Ja, ich würde sagen, Thomas Uhmann kann äh jetzt sein Leben ungeniert weiterführen, weil der Ruf ist durch.
Der Ruf ist ruiniert, ja.
Na ja, wer weiß, ob ihr sicherlich jetzt auch alles daran setzen äh in irgendeiner Form. Ähm,
in Berufung zu gehen und seinen äh Rahmen, seinen Namen zu
säubern. Um noch kurz zu sagen, die Z neun Verwaltungs GmbH, die ich ja am Rande genannt habe, das war ja auch seine Firma, deren Geschäftsführer er war, ja. Äh es geht wirklich eigentlich nur um rund um rund um diesen, um diesen Menschen.
Ciao. So, jetzt sind wir eigentlich schon durch.
Ja, jetzt können wir noch ein bisschen für den Congress werben.
Genau, außer ja schon ein paar Mal getan haben,
Tickets gibt's leider keine mehr für Kurzentschlossene. Also wer von euch unseren äh früheren Aufräum äh Aufrufen nicht Folge geleistet hat oder sich dadurch äh ausreichend aufgeschreckt gefühlt hat,
Da sieht's jetzt leider schlecht aus, der Kongress ist hoffnungslos ausverkauft. Ähm,
und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, dass da auch schon eine ganze Menge Leute in Bittsteller Haltung so auf die Knie gegangen sind, aber auch da werden, glaube ich, äh,
nicht viel wird nicht viel gemacht werden können, weil solche Gebäude haben halt einfach mal einen Kapazitätsgrenze und die ist erreicht.
Erstaunlich ist. Ich meine, das ist jetzt der zweiunddreißig C drei, das ist die vierte Veranstaltung, die wir da jetzt machen in Hamburg.
Also es hat nur vier Jahre gedauert.
Gebäude, von dem man sich vorher gar nicht vorstellen konnte, dass man's auch nur ansatzweise angereichert bekommen würde mit Personen, ist jetzt auch schon wieder am, ja, an der Kapazitätsgrenze angelangt. Das ist wirklich ähm blöd. Das ist auch,
Blöd für die Zukunft, weil,
Wir hatten diese Situation leider schon einmal, als wir eben hier noch in Berlin waren. Berliner Kongresszentrum ist jetzt auch kein kleines Gebäude, aber eben für den Kongress überhaupt nicht mehr ausreichend gewesen und da lag so das Limit irgendwo so bei dreitausendfünfhundert Leuten, glaube ich.
Und das war dann eben auch erreicht und wir hatten dann so eine Phase von mehreren Jahren,
Wo es halt immer wieder äh Probleme gab wegen Tickets und ähm teilweise ist es auch nicht gelungen, da,
die richtige Art und Weise zu reagieren und dann wurden halt alle möglichen Verfahren ausprobiert und Lotterie hier und äh andere Sachen und das war einfach alles nicht besonderlich,
Besonders ähm glücklicher ist. Ich glaube, die offiziell gab's keine keine Lotterie, aber sagen wir mal, das technische Versagen, das Ticketservers äh,
Dadurch lief es zwangsläufig darauf hinaus, dass er dann sozusagen eine Lotterie stattfand und das ist natürlich das Allerschlimmste, was man eigentlich tun kann, weil,
Man dadurch natürlich gefährdet, dass Leute auf die Veranstaltung kommen, die da schon immer hingehen,
Nicht, dass ich der Meinung bin, dass ich auf so einer Veranstaltung nur Leute tummeln sollten, die schon immer da waren. Du brauchst bloß eine gewisse,
Brauchst du eine gewisse Basis an an alten Hasen und Helsinnen,
damit einfach auch so der Modus dieser Veranstaltung äh korrekt weiter kommuniziert wird, einfach um diese Kontinuität, äh die die Veranstaltung einfach hat, zu wahren.
Na ja, müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir damit jetzt umgehen,
ohnehin noch einige Umwälzungen an, was das Gebäude betrifft. Jetzt freuen wir uns erstmal, dass dass der Kongress ist,
Du hast äh auch vor Kurzem noch einen kleinen Vortrag gegeben beim äh Abend mit einem Überblick über Veranstaltungen.
Ja, da habe ich mal ein paar rausgesucht. Ähm ich tue mich da ja immer ein bisschen ein bisschen schwer. Ähm.
Einzelne herauszunehmen oder so einzelne herauszustellen, da soll natürlich sollen alle Leute ihre eigenen,
ihre eigenen Events finden und vor allem gibt's ja auch die die Workshops und die Es und allerhand anderes noch, ja, also die Vorträge sind ja ähm.
Auch nur ein Teil, ja.
Auch nur ein Teil und ähm,
Wenn ich mal grob die äh die Kapazitäten der Seele addiere, dann sind wir bei vier, fünf, sechs, zwei,
Also höchstens so sieben äh knapp siebentausend Leute können,
Gleichzeitig in Vorträgen sein. Mir bleiben immer noch äh fünftausend über die sich anderen Aktivitäten zuwenden, wenn alle Seele voll sind.
Ja klar, aber ich meine, wir sprechen jetzt hier gerade ohnehin zu einer äh Öffentlichkeit, die nochmal die Teilnehmerzahl des Kongresses übersteigt und viele werden sich wahrscheinlich das Ganze dann ohnehin auch aus der Ferne anschauen, ob sie nun wollen oder nicht, also ob sie nun
Also ob's jetzt nicht vielleicht anders gehabt hätten oder nicht. Sprich, das sind ja auch Streaming-Tipps.
Eier, streaming Tipps, Streaming Tipps. Ja, genau, also kann man sich anschauen.
Verlinken sozusagen auch mal deine dein Überblick.
Kleiner, kleiner, subjektiver, unvollständiger, zeitlich beschränkter, völlig äh verzerrter äh Blick auf den, auf ein paar
Talks des äh zweiunddreißig C3, die zufällig ausgewählt wurden an dieser Stelle.
Ja, weiß nicht, was ist so dein Gefühl.
Wobei?
In Bezug auf die Veranstaltung, dies Jahr.
Ja, ich freue mich sehr. Ich äh äh sehe mit mit mit.
Mit etwas Sorge, wie jedes Jahr, wie viele Leute sich gerade wieder kaputt fahren für den ganzen Spaß und ähm.
Ja, ist ein ziemlicher Verschleiß.
Ja, der dieses Jahr nochmal mehr ans Material geht, äh weil das Camp ja noch gar nicht das Camp ist ja noch gar nicht verheilt.
Aber es wird eine es wird ein großer Spaß. Also es wird eine große Freude und man ähm,
Es ist schön zu sehen, wie sich jetzt alle, ja, schon, wie viele sich da jetzt auch auf diese Veranstaltung schon freuen und ich tue das natürlich auch.
Genau und vielleicht auch nochmal so ein Satz zu den Leuten, die das erste Mal da sind. Die gibt's ja bestimmt wieder, weil ich auch grad so ein paar Tweets gesehen habe. So, ha, erstmal Kongress, worauf soll ich achten?
Ich würde ja gerne so ein paar falsche unbedingt am ersten Tag nein, es ist.
Nee, aber wenn ihr wenn ihr sozusagen die Möglichkeit habt, ähm einen Tag früher da hinzukommen, also kommt nicht am ersten Tag,
Das ist schon mal so ein so ein Tipp, den ich geben kann.
Kommt nicht erst am ersten, da kommt schon auch.
Ja, stimmt. Richtig. Genau, es gibt ja es gibt ja in der in der Kongresssprache äh den Tag null,
Ähm Tag null ist halt klar, der äh sechsundzwanzigste Dezember,
und das ist halt so der Hauptaufbautag oder sagen wir mal, wo am meisten äh sichtbare Aktivität ist und wo man sich halt auch selber schon extrem einbringen kann. Also,
überhaupt sich den Engeln anzuschließen, kann man nur empfehlen. Das ist die beste Möglichkeit, in diese Veranstaltung und in diese Community auch reinzukommen, weil man eben auch gleich den Kongress so ein bisschen von innen sieht, was dazu beiträgt und von daher auch ähm darüber sehr gut Anschluss findet.
Ja, ich denke, das ist auch einfach ein guter Weg, um Leute kennenzulernen. Man kann sich auch gleich an der Stelle einbringen, wo man
ja auch die eigene Expertise oder zumindest das eigene Interesse sieht. Und vor allem ist es sehr hilfreich,
schon mal einen Tag über diese Veranstaltung zu latschen, ohne dass sie in full operation ist, einfach nur, um einen Überblick zu bekommen, was eigentlich wo ist. Also gerade, wenn man das CCH nicht kennt und da so rumläuft.
Bis man mal diese ganzen Etagen
drauf hat und über welche Treppe man jetzt eigentlich wohin kommt und welchen Schleichweg es jetzt noch gibt und wo jetzt irgendwie noch ein Kaffeestand ist und wo kriege ich eigentlich was zu essen und wo wo sind die Nerds und wo wo ist hier irgendwie äh der Ort mit den geilen drei D Druckern? Also all diese ganzen Sachen, die will man
möglichst früh schon mal auschecken,
Allein, dass man dann einfach im vollgewuselt des ersten und zweiten Tages dann einfach noch die Orientierung behält. Beziehungsweise auch schon selber Auskunft geben kann, wenn man gefragt wird.
Ich finde das ja eigentlich, dass äh das Schöne bei bei solchen Veranstaltungen ist,
Das Rumlaufen und das verloren gehen. Also ich finde zum Beispiel,
Wer jetzt mehrere Male schon mit dem mit dem Anfertigen von äh Übersichtsplänen beschäftigt gewesen, die ich für völlig äh,
fehlgeleitet, also für die völlig falsche Idee, da eine Karte äh zu reichen, ja? Also man muss einfach überall hingehen und sich alles anschauen und ich finde es mit das Schönste, wenn ich irgendwo,
rumlaufe, dort eben mich auch zu verlieren und einfach mal ein bisschen einzutauchen und mitzuschwimmen.
Und das ist eigentlich das einzig das ist das das was ich allen ans Herz lege lauf da rum, schaut euch Dinge an, quatscht andere an, guckt euch an was die Essenplease machen ähm,
Und wandert herum,
Das ist eigentlich das, was ich mache in den wenigen Stunden, die ich da vielleicht mal irgendwie Zeit habe, dass ich einfach rumlatsche, mir Sachen angucke.
Ja, kann man auch machen.
Treiben, also dieses Treiben, ne, also auch null und so, ne. Und man immer noch an Tag vier irgendwelche Sachen entdecken kann ist schon toll.
Ja.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, sich mal in Ruhe das äh Vortragsprogramm anzuschauen. Einfach um mal zu gucken, ob's irgendetwas gibt, was man wirklich,
unbedingt sehen will und dann sollte man vielleicht auch dafür sorgen, dass man da möglichst frühzeitig drin ist,
Ja und sonst? Durchhalten. Spart euch eure Kräfte auf, geht noch mal zur Grippeimpfung.
Danke. Herr Girl.
Grippeimpfung, kann ich auch sehr empfehlen.
Man muss sich da klarmachen, dass da eben auch nochmal ein bisschen mal eben die Welt zusammenkommt und ähm äh,
nicht nur um elektronische Viren, also gesund bleiben ist einfach,
Ist eine hohe Kunst und äh mir ist es in den letzten Jahren erstaunlicherweise äh gut gelungen und da gehören einfach auch so ganz einfache Sachen dazu, wie zum Beispiel, ja.
Willst du mir jetzt erzählen, wie man beim Kongress gesund bleibt? Ich bitte dich.
Ja. Wieso?
Bist du nicht gesund geblieben?
Gesund, bin ich geblieben. Ich war durch und total fettig, aber das war was anderes. Weil ich war nicht krank.
Aha. Nee, weiß ich nicht. Was äh was was sind die Tipps, um gesund zu bleiben? Viel schlafen. Wollte, würdest du doch jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen, oder? Hände waschen. Hände. Hände waschen.
Das hilft? Händewaschen, genau. Hände. Was ganz einfach. Einfach Hände waschen, also wie wann auch immer ihr irgendwo an so einem Klo vorbeigeht und äh ihr müsst nicht gerade mal zehn Sekunden später irgendwo ganz wichtig sein. Einfach nochmal Hände waschen.
Und Sachen nicht in Mund nehmen.
Also.
Ja grundsätzlich, also Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, aber erstmal nix im Mund, ne. Gucken ist mit mit Augen.
Genau. Nicht so viel. Ja, na gut. Das reicht, glaube ich, erstmal.
Ja, diese Ticketsituation, zu der äußere ich mich ungern,
Aber es ist ja jetzt hauen und Stechentag. Hauen und Stechenzeit, wo diejenigen, die äh,
Es trotzer Warnungen und Hinweise nicht geschafft haben, sich ein Ticket zu organisieren. Äh jetzt dann doch noch welche haben wollen und ähm es auch Leute gibt, die Tickets abgeben,
Ähm wir haben da im Vicky so eine Ticket Tauschbörsenseite. Ähm und ähm,
Achtet einfach nur darauf, dass ihr die möglichst aus
vertrauenswürdigen Quellen dann übertragen bekommt die Tickets und dass sie auch bitte nur das zahlt was drauf steht, denn wenn wir jetzt in Richtung einer
voraussichtlich regelmäßig ausverkauften Veranstaltungen kommen, dann sind auch irgendwelche ähm Ticketgrabber und Schwarzmarkthändler nicht weit
und das wäre wirklich ärgerlich,
Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, äh falls euch irgendjemand Tickets zum überhöhten Preis anbietet, ähm müsste man sich mal darüber Gedanken machen.
Ob da nicht, ob man da nicht eine Lösung findet.
Tag, am zweiten Tag ist noch 'ne Option mit Kindern auf den Kongress zu kommen.
Ich kenne da im Moment nicht die Regelung, aber ja wahrscheinlich, äh,
Wir haben aber jetzt gerade, glaube ich, äh noch vereinbart, dass wir eine Sendung Sendung vom Kongress machen werden,
werden wir einen besonderen Gast für euch haben, über den ihr euch sicherlich freuen werdet. Dann gibt's eine Sendung vom Kongress und ansonsten kann ich nur
Wenn ich eine Empfehlung geben würde für das für den Kongress dann wäre die seit an Tag eins früh wach und geht zu Opening und Kino. Das wird bestimmt ein großes Fest.
Und alles andere auch.
Genau. Wir kommen zum Ende.
Ja, wir kommen zum Ende. Man merkt auch, ähm wir sind durch durch.
Das so früh am Morgen.
Naja, dass das so früh in der Woche, könnte man fast sagen, ne.
Schon Donnerstag.
Ja, wir müssen da jetzt irgendwie mal äh noch so diesen Kongress machen.
Dann äh machen wir's kurz, Danksagungen.
Ah ja, danke an Frank und Alexander.
Genau. Und auch noch mal einen Dank an Peter für fortgesetzte Unterstützung und danke fürs Zuhören. Das war's.
Zweitausendfünfzehn Bundespressekonferenz.
Gern Böhmer, man haben geringe Aussicht auf Anerkennung. Sie haben Polizei, wir haben deutsche Soldaten, sie haben Polizei, wir haben die Vereinigten Staaten, sie haben Polizei, wir haben gute Erfahrungen,
Sie haben Polizei, wir haben Videoüberwachung, junge Polizei. Ähm wir haben über ein Gesetzespaket, sie haben Polizei, ganz sicher ist es nicht so konkret. Sie haben die Polizei, wir haben Gewalt,
politischen Gründen. Wir haben Paragraph zehntausend, deswegen wird's mit einer Zögerung stattfinden. Sie haben gesehen, sie haben Polizei, sie haben Polizei, sie haben Polizei,
Wir haben, wir haben, wir haben, wir haben, wir haben es, deutsche Militär, wir haben Tornados. Wir haben die Bundeswehr, sie haben, sie haben Polizei, sie haben Polizei,
Polizei,
Wir haben, wir haben die Art, wir haben, wir haben das deutsche Militär, wir haben Raketen, wir haben wir haben Polizei, wir haben Kraus-Maffei Wegmann, die HP Polizei, wir haben das Bundeskriminalamt, sie haben Polizei, wir haben Grenzkontrollen, sie haben Polizei,
Das kann niemand wollen. Wir haben Polizei. Wir haben Staatsanwaltschaften. Sie haben Polizei, wir haben Tochtergesellschaften,
Sie haben Polizei. Wir haben die Verbindungsdaten bis in den Gesetzentwurf geregelt bei schwersten Straftaten. Aber da kann Herr Plate, was die Gesetze anbelangt.
Sicherlich mehr zu sagen. Sie haben Polizei, wir haben Erkenntnisse,
Bundesregierung begrüßt die Ergebnisse der Beständnisse. Sie haben Polizei, wir haben Teil und das Geld. Wir haben alles Sebastian Bundeskanzlerin gefällt. Aber sie haben, sie haben es Polizei, sie haben Polizei, sie haben Polizei,
Wir haben, wir haben die haben, wir haben, wir haben das deutsche Militär, wir haben große Panzer, wir haben die Bundeswehr, sie haben sie haben, sie haben Polizei, sie haben Polizei, sie haben Polizei, wir haben, wir haben, wir haben, wir haben, wir haben die Bundeswehr, wir haben Stromgewehre,
Innenminister. Ja.